these Skillet Roll-Ups are like many
single sered lasagnas each with their
own crispy top just like an edge piece
they're packed with sauteed veggies
fresh herbs and cottage cheese too which
gives them a big boost of Protein Plus
they're the perfect midweek dinner to
get you out of a rush because they're
more fun than classic lasagna and tastes
lighter and fresher too the hardest part
is probably filling and cutting the
rolls but just remember it does not have
to be perfect you'll start by dividing
the filling between each of the cooked
lasagna noodles and then rolling each
one up into this super cute coil but to
make them mini you've got to cut them in
half which I find easiest to do with
kitchen twine or unflavored dental floss
but you can also just use a serrated
knife all that's left to do is Nestle
them into some marinara sauce in the
skillet and then send them to the oven
where the cheese will melt and the tops
will crisp try them once as is and then
have fun playing around with all sorts
of different fillings